we're going to talk about the equations
that describe how a capacitor works
and then i'll give you an example of how
these how these equations work
so the basic equation of a capacitor
says that the charge q
on a capacitor is equal to the
capacitance value
times the voltage across the capacitor
okay so here's our capacitor over here
let's say we have a voltage on it of
plus or minus v
it has we say it has a capacitance value
of c
and that's a property of of this device
here and c is equal to just looking at
the equation over there c is equal to
the ratio of the charge stored in the
capacitor divided by the voltage on the
capacitor
so what we mean by stored charge
is
if a current flows into this capacitor
it can leave some excess charge
on the top i'll just mark that with plus
signs and there'll be a corresponding
set of minus charges on the other other
plate of the capacitor
this collection of excess charge
will
will be q plus
and this down here will be q minus and
they're going to be the same value
and what we say here is when the
capacitors in this state we say it's
storing
this much charge and we'll just name one
of these numbers here and they're going
to be the same with opposite signs so
that's what it means for a capacitor to
store charge
so what i want to do now is develop some
sort of expression that relates the
current through a capacitor
to the voltage so we wanted to develop
we want to develop an
iv characteristic so this will
correspond to sort of like ohm's law for
a capacitor what relates the current to
the voltage
so the way i'm going to do that is to
exercise this equation by causing some
changes and in particular we'll change
the voltage
on this capacitor and we'll see what
happens
over here so when we say we're going to
change a voltage that means we're going
to create something a condition of
of dv dt
the change in voltage per change in time
and so i can do that by taking the
derivative of both sides of this
equation here i've already done it for
this side and over here what i'll have
is dq
dt
and i took the derivative of both sides
just to be sure i treated both sides of
the equation the same
so let's look at this little expression
right here this is kind of interesting
this is change of charge
with change of time and that's equal to
that's what we mean by current
that is current and the symbol for
current is i
so
dq dt is current essentially by
definition we give it the symbol i
and that's going to be equal to c
dv
dt
and this is an important equation
that's
basically the the iv
relationship between
current and voltage in a capacitor
and what it tells us that the current is
actually proportional to and the
proportionality constant is c
the current is proportional to the rate
of change of voltage not to the voltage
itself but to the rate of change of
voltage
all right now what i want to do is
find an expression that expresses v in
terms of i so here here we have i in
terms of dv dt let's figure out if we
can express v in terms of some
expression containing i
the way i do that is i need to eliminate
this derivative here and what i'm going
to do that by taking the integral of
this side of the equation
and at the same time i'll take the
integral of the other side of the
equation to keep everything equal
so what that looks like is
the integral
of i
with respect to time
is equal to
the integral
of c
dv
dt
with respect to time
and on this side i have basically
i do something like this and i have the
integral of dv
so this is this looks like an
anti-derivative this is an integral
acting like an anti-derivative
and what is it what function
has a derivative of dv
and that would be just plain v
so i can rewrite this side of the
equation constant c comes out of the
expression
and we end up with v on this side just
plain v and that equals the integral of
i
dt
so we're part way through we're
developing what's going to be called an
integral form of the capacitor iv
equation
what i need to look at next is what are
the bounds on this integral
so the bounds on this integral are
basically minus
time equals minus infinity
to time equals
some time t which is sort of like the
time now
and that equals capacitance times
voltage
and let me take the c over on the other
side and actually i'm going to move v
over here on to the left
and then
i can write this 1 over c
this is the normal looking version of
this equation
i
dt
and minus infinity
to time t t time big t is time right now
and what this says it says that the
voltage on a capacitor has something to
do with the summation or the integral
of the current over its entire life all
the way back to t equals minus infinity
and this is not so convenient what we're
going to do instead is we're going to
pick a time and we'll call it
we'll pick a time called t equals 0
and we'll say that the voltage on the
capacitor
was equal to
let's say v naught
with some value and then what we'll do
is we're going to change the limit on
our integral here from minus infinity to
time t equals zero and then then we'll
use the integral from instead zero to
the time we're interested in so that
equation looks like this we're just
going to change the limits on the
on the integral
and we have the integral now but we have
to actually account for all the time
before t equals zero and what we do
there is we just basically add
v naught whatever v naught is that's the
starting point at time equals zero and
then the integral takes us from time
zero until time now
this is the integral form of the
capacitor equation and i want to
actually make one more little change
this is the current at v of as a
function of big t
what we really want to write here is we
want to write v of a little t just this
is just stylistically this is what we
like this equation to look like
and so i want my the limits on my
integral to be zero to little t and now
i need to sort of make up a a new
replacement for this t that's inside
here i can call it something else i can
call it i
of we'll call it i'll call it tau
this is basically just a little fake
variable
d tau
plus
v
naught
and this is now we finally have it this
is
the integral form of the capacitor
equation
we have the other form of the equation
that goes with this which was i
equals big c
dv
dt
so there's the two forms of the
capacitor equation
now i want to do an example with this
one here just to see how how this it
works when we have a capacitor circuit